it's extremely hard to publish an
archive every one of my papers
was rejected at archive
this is cornell university's uh
depository they usually uh
publish there before they go on to try
to publish an uh prestigious journal
uh
uh
the first time that i tried to publish
they had no idea who i was and when i
send them
i think one or two of my
uh previously published papers also uh
that i have a doctorate a mechanical and
aerospace engineer from case western
reserve university in cleveland ohio
when i send this to them they basically
said so what is this so what uh you know
uh we we need you
no not at all uh we need you to get uh
some some sort of sponsor so that's when
i started writing to notable physicists
that
i assumed you know could could possibly
sponsor the work one of them was uh
professor catalan another one was
professor maldasena of the advanced
institute
at princeton
um
unfortunately neither would sponsor the
work so i just gave up and went with the
patent route
so you don't just have one patent you
have three and you had trouble with only
one is that correct and the other two
were fine
actually there were five patent
applications put in there was a high
energy electromagnetic field generator
it received the pattern
there was the craft using an inertial
mass reduction device that received the
pattern after a lot of going back and
forth with the primary examiner and mr
philip bonzell
a great great man by the way very very
very technically apt
uh he posed some very
key questions that
like for example fortunate enough
again he said how can you produce i mean
neutron stars for goodness sake again
can you know and electric fields on the
order of 10 to the 18 volts per meter
you're talking about the schwinger limit
and commensurate with b fields on the
order of 10 to the 9 tesla again that
equals cb
relationship um
so
he really knew his stuff and we were
able against uh
one of the things that i send you uh did
that uh primary examiner interview
uh that
there are a series of slides
that aided to his acceptance of uh
of uh
that pattern the allowance of that
pattern here we had a very strong appeal
uh that was based partially on that
phone interview and
where the slide presentation was
presented and that got us through on
that one now another one was the high
frequency gravitational wave generator
that pattern application also received
that was the first office allowance that
went through extremely smoothly
which for the controversial subject
matter discussed was very interesting
and
then there were two more there are room
temperature superconductor
uh which we actually changed the name to
high temperature superconductor thinking
maybe that
will make the primary examiner more
more malleable it did it
and so that pattern application and the
last one a plasma compression fusion
device which was i was fortunate enough
to actually publish in ieee
transaction on plasma science a very
prestigious journal
uh of plasma physics
especially uh
which deals with nuclear fusion
actual
production of nuclear fusion and
um the chief editor of of the found it
very
very refreshing i still remember one of
the comments
um
again it's it's
these are new ideas they're quite
some people call them revolutionary some
people call them breakthrough
any which way these are new perspectives
on old physics i would not call these
new physics at all right because they're
based on all physics it's just a new
interpretation for example the the whole
idea of the super force how the super
force can the rise in einstein classical
relativity for
formalism even though
the super force is really blank energy
divided by plank length meaning it is
the blank force so it acts at the blank
scale
again
just new ways of looking at all physics
that's all this is